foreign
is
[Music]
i'm delegating here
because
[Music]
wow
um
um so during the break i just got a few
questions from uh sort of the quantum
prelims for things so um i thought it'd
be good to maybe take a minute to just
make sure uh all the quantum notation
i'm going to use in the slides makes
sense um so now it's like the time to
sort of ask any question you want just
like when i'm writing these like pies
and states and like norms and stuff like
what do i mean um so just quickly to
clarify one thing like if i have like a
quantum state psi so i represented by
this unit vector here
we can think of like a projective
measurement so this measurement pi g
right it has the
if i apply this measurement to this
state
right this is a two outcome event so one
of two things is going to happen either
if my state will collapse to being here
or it'll collapse to being here
this here corresponds to pi g times psi
this here would be i minus pi g times
psi um and so when i talk about this
state the sort of classical analog is
like this is the this is a corresponding
to like a an event where i like
conditioned on a certain outcome like
i've conditioned on the event that uh
this measurement accepted on this stage
and i i get the state um i've been a
little sloppy about the normalizations
so i was actually talking about trying
to get like this state with probability
one and more normally when you want to
do that you want to renormalize this so
you have to like this state may have a
is norm is not one in particular the
norm squared is p the probability that
you get there
so um any questions uh before i go
on what does it mean from the
algebra kind of
sense yeah so okay when i talk about
production i'm sort of using projections
and subspaces interchangeably like when
i say like a projection pie um i'm often
thinking about like the the subspace uh
expand by this projections like the
image of pi
um
so okay then this jordan's llama thing
was about well like what happens it's
like in general like linear algebra when
i have two subspaces and they intersect
right so if i have like two one
dimensional subspace and they intersect
like they intersect at like a single
angle
right
and uh like if i have like a plane and a
line they also intersect at an angle but
more generally like if i have two high
dimensional subspaces like what does it
mean like what does our intersection
look like and jordan's lemma is just
like a way to think about that it says
that i can actually like
think about like
like two subspaces in high dimensions
actually need it like a set of angles
um and you can like look at like
different spices where actually it it
does look like a
two lines and meeting at an angle
yes yes yes sorry um so yeah when i look
at these particular slices um i can
recover the whole space by doing like a
direct sum of all these like 2d slices i
think they're all going to be orthogonal
to each other
so um
thanks everyone for coming um so this is
gonna be part two of the rewinding
tutorial
um so
titled how to run a quantum attacker
many times or uh the unreasonable
effectiveness of alternating projectors
so basically all the technical stuff in
this talk is going to use this one
technique
and this is based on joint work with all
center casa explainer and mark hendry
all right so
in the first talk we saw how to use
unruhe's rewinding technique to prove
post-quantum soundness of plum
and it was nice to let us say something
about the post quantum soundness but
there were sort of obvious drawbacks
like the moment we saw it um like we got
a really bad soundness guarantee uh so
we uh wrote down like 0.9 bound and said
you could actually do better but still
even if you do better like using the
full wounder's level uh it doesn't rule
out something like a quantum attacker
breaking blum with probability 0.7 and
deep down it's like very very
unsatisfying right you have this
protocol where if you had both if you
won twice you would clearly um
be uh
it's clearly like a guess instance but
if you have a quantum attacker that's
doing this winning with probably 0.7 we
really couldn't say anything using that
technique was it actually broken
um so
that's quite a strange phenomenon um
and a more serious issue with this
rewinding technique is that it really
gets stuck at uh well at two rewinds or
you can generalize it a little past two
you can turns out you can go to a
constant number of rewinds but that
still limits you to a really narrow
class of protocols um for instance you
can do blunt we had to like take that
protocol very carefully for that first
talk
because if we had used the original uh
zero knowledge protocol for np and gmw
recoloring we wouldn't have been able to
do it you need to in that protocol each
each opening reveal like one edge or one
the colors of two vertices and you'd
have to rewind many many times to get
the color from the whole graph so
totally unclear how you would do that
for me
so what do we know about amplification
so i know i know you would like to get
it better just by itself but could we
amplify it in some way or does something
weird happens here um
amplifying what sounds like very very
repeating right
yeah so um
and so if you just want to put for
blonde like yeah
yeah you can you can amplify that and
get negligible soundness there yes
using understanding
because it says that if any adversary
wins at all then with noticeable
probability i will succeed in extracting
uh
like a
cycle and like one of the repetitions
all right so for this talk we're going
to see a significantly more powerful
rewinding technique that's going to
solve these problems like if i apply it
to blom i'm going to get one half sound
this error um and i'm also going to
handle a lot more protocols than just uh
two special sound protocols one where
you just need two rewinds
and so these issues arise because we
want to rely on your computation as well
if you wanted to do
stronger forms
perfect binding yeah yeah exactly good
good
so for gmw three coloring yeah if
they're statistically binding fitments
you can do it you can prove soundness uh
proof of knowledge
still okay
um but uh there's one nice example where
you can't cheat like this
so for gw
handle uh
provides the cheap property one very
close to one
uh does that
is is the issue that you have to handle
any non-trivial cheating or even this
guy is from romantic uh if it's like
really really close to one yeah i think
it's it's fine
one minus
one over the number of edges or
something you know like uh
no i don't think you can prove anything
non-trivial
like if it's very much more i think one
over m squared i think
yes
i mean there's a parallel reputation of
the soundness uh parallel amplification
of the sound
um
yeah so good uh so yeah that works for
things like blonde parallel repetition
doesn't help you for things like gmw
though because it doesn't the problem
with gmw is not the soundest error
really it's the like the number of
rewinds you need to succeed right you'll
still always need to extract a graph in
like one of your repetitions or a
coloring in one of your repetitions
right so the only way to do that is to
is to see
all the openings you need enough rewinds
but in either case you're losing zk so
oh no no you can you can get like a
there you can get a really bad zombies
error because we can do many rewinds if
you're really really close to
probability what is really really it's
one minus one over poly m
i think i would guess i i guess yeah
of them all being um
yeah yeah so it can be like
but if p is one minus one over n squared
then maybe it's fine
one over into the c and then you repeat
the parallel
many enough and you can get the sound
sequential repetition
i do not think you'll be able to argue
with parallel repetition the way you
argue parallel repetition for blah must
be a direct argument to the parallel
revolution and not by amplifying
in fact i don't yeah i don't i don't
know how to argue about parallel
repetitions for like these set of signal
protocols except i think the technique
that fermi gives in this talk actually
gives an approach for doing so but
we don't have like general techniques
right to analyze the parallel petition
of a second protocol
right
it does work but arguments it doesn't
work
yeah sorry
so the difference is that this is only
computational sound yeah but if your
protocol goes we are
somewhere statistical finding that
so that would work for most of the cases
but in the last the what he's going to
say it's not going to work compressing
protocols or succinct protocols
no even if you have the right definition
of collapsing here uh with like with
universe technique you're not going to
be able to say anything interesting it's
like computational soundness
except for like the close to one i i
don't think i
um know how to get that down without
using this technique so we can uh maybe
take this uh
right
with uh with uh collapse like you could
get some knowledge
and then you can repeat uh sequentially
evangelists um right that that would
give you a good protocol right
uh
now why are you happy with that protocol
uh you know one reason i can see is that
he wants a sickness and this technique
won't give you one applying the succinct
yeah and also just having more
repetitions just inherently undesirable
for protocols
um right if you need a polynomial number
of rounds of interaction it's very um
yeah a natural progression of the talk
will reveal additional reasons why
you're not
um
right so
a motivating example uh like instead of
picking gmw uh as i would have an
example i'm going to use
killian sustained arguments for np
so what is a sustained argument
for us today is going to be an
interactive protocol between two parties
approver and a verifier
the trooper is trying to convince the
verifier that some statement is true
and the goal of this thing's argument is
to do much better than just sending the
verifier the witness and the clear
and that's what the succinct wants the
sync wants the total communication to
the bit length of this transcript
both both directions of communication
plus the total runtime of the verifier
is as a polylogarithmic dependence on
the size of the instance and as the
witness
okay so
compared to just reading the witness
this should be essentially exponentially
better
much much better
um and to get this succinctness you're
almost certainly going to have to relax
the soundness guarantee to only be
computational so your sound is only
going to hold against efficient cheating
provers
um
so in the early 90s the killian
constructs this four message succinct
argument protocol for all of np just
assuming uh the existence of collision
resistant hash functions which are a
relatively mild assumption in crypto and
this is kind of the amazing statement it
says like under a
weak computational assumption
um
i think it's possible to
really really really efficiently verify
an np statement
um like i have like this let's say
enormous threes that instance i can
convince you uh we've agreed on some
enormous reset instance i can convince
you that it's satisfiable with just a
few bits of communication
it's really uh cool like an intuitive
level you can do this
and there's also been many applications
both in theory and in practice
um
so
extra motivation for focusing on this
example
like beyond the fact that we really want
to get uh succinct arguments secure
against quantum attacks
um studying quantum rewinding precinct
arguments is going to force us to
develop general purpose techniques and
the
sort of high-level reason for this is
that typically the way we prove
soundness is by
using multiple transcripts to specify
some witness
and with a succinct argument you need a
lot of transcripts right so
by their nature the transcripts are
really short like way way shorter than
the witness so if you want to argue
soundness of this by
getting lots of transcripts and
specifying a witness you're going to
need like some polynomial number of
transcripts
so unlike last talk where we just had
two transcripts specify a witness which
is think arguments you need a lot
so we're going to focus on this example
and
to make things a little more concrete
let me just remind you how killian's
protocol works
so this protocol is basically a
cryptographic compiler that starts from
any pcp and turns it into an interactive
argument system using crypto um so let
me just be clear about like why a pcp
isn't already a succinct argument
because sort of has this feeling that
the verifier is only looking at a few
bits
the reason is the model right the pcp is
only sound in a model where the approver
has written down the whole bcp in
advance
right and
if it's actually an interaction if the
prover is dishonest how do i know that
they've written down a pcp in advance
when i asked to see a position they
could sort of answer adaptively and so
that's the intuition behind killian's
protocols throw crypto at the problem
and turn it into a protocol that rules
this possibility out
so
a little bit more formally the way it
works is that the first two messages of
the protocol are basically a commitment
to this pcp and it's a very special kind
of commitment so the verifier sends a
collision assistant hash function
description of the approver and the
prover is going to encode this pcp
or it's going to hash this pcp off in
this tree that's tree of treatments so
then takes the hash function takes in
two blocks and spits out one block and
then you take two blocks instead of
another block and then you send the root
of this tree over to the verifier and so
this is a commitment to that long pct
but it has a special property that later
when you want to run the tcp
verification you don't have to open the
whole beat the whole clinic you don't
have to show all of the pcp you can just
show a local opening so for instance the
verifier wants to see this black square
what the prover can do is supply this
local opening consisting of these blue
squares which are just the siblings and
the leafs on the root to leaf path um
and using that the verifier can just
sort of hatch its way back up and just
confirm that that thing was open
correctly so at the end of the protocol
the verifier accepts if the pcp check
passes and all the openings are valid
okay so that's the whole protocol um but
how do you prove uh soundness
so classically the way you do it is
while you're trying to you have to
formalize this intuition that the crhs
is really forcing you to respond
consistently with one pcp or you want to
invoke the soundness of the pcb system
to say that if x is not in the language
then the approver can't convince the
verifier
so yeah so just the size of the hash has
to be lost like
the output yeah so any any amount of
compression at all like if the hash one
can take some n bits and spits on mis1
you can compose that and get it to spit
out n over two and that's what you need
here you need to take n and set out n
over two bits and that's what you need
to
make this construction work
there's any amount of compression
okay so the way that you formally prove
this secure classically is you just you
rewind these last few messages many many
times um
just to show what it means to rewind
many times like why that works here um
what the reduction reduction's doing is
they want many attempting transcripts
and what happens when you run this
program many times and record a lot of
accepting transcripts is you fall into
one of two cases right so in one case
all the transcripts you get are
consistent with each other
and then you're going to record a tcp
and what's going to happen is this pcp
you can show essentially captures the
success probability of the original
malicious prover and so if it's too high
then you're going to get a contradiction
pcp shouldn't
exist the other possibility is that the
answers are inconsistent and the amazing
property of this merkle tree is that
whenever this happens this means that
there is a pl that the prover found a
collision in the hash function
so computational assumptions rule out
the second case
okay so i'm going to jump straight to
the quantum setting
and sort of ask like what is the problem
when you try to make that exact same
argument happen when your approver is a
malicious
quantum attacker
and i'm just going to define this
quantity success probability p
so this is just the probability that
this prover
wins on a random challenge r so
i'm zooming in on the last two messages
of the protocol here so i'm for the rest
of this talk basically fixing the first
two messages and i'm assuming that i
have approver who is still successful
over like the randomness of the rest of
the protocol
so that's what i mean by success
probability
um
and as we saw in the first talk the
issue here is that
this rewinding argument relies on the
fact that i can just repeatedly query
and get many transcripts but
here like after the very first query
my leftover state correspond to an
adversary whose success probability is
lower right and so who lets us show that
okay it's actually not too low condition
on the first one succeeding um but in
this case that's not going to take us
very far we want to get a lot of
transcripts so we really have to tackle
this problem of the test probability
being cuba
so i'm just going to quickly overview
what we do
it's kind of the only thing you could
try in hindsight
what we're going to do is find a way to
fix this problem we're going to take
this adversary whose success probability
is too low and run some quantum
algorithm that will make its success
probability high again it's going to
spit out a new adversary because the
custom probability is back to its
original key and that's going to be this
this whole talk is how you do this
you have a damaged adversary state
you're going to recover a good one
and
is it easy to see why the success
quality goes down
oh no i'm not saying it has to it could
go up we just don't know
like all we know is um that says like it
doesn't go down by too much um there
there's actually a example you can show
um
so i can give you examples where it will
go down
can you extract the way the vector
commitment primitive and talk about
instruction
surprisingly the notion of collapsing is
a little bit annoying to use with vector
commands so
we thought about that and it was a
little bit uh unclear like this issue of
like measurement is a little like
measuring the opening it's a little bit
hairy when like which position you're
opening is like not clear um i wouldn't
like i'm not that confident that like
there isn't a way but i i we didn't come
up with one paper
with very high probability
uh you can make this analysis go through
but then repeating it would basically
skills the sequence so yeah
yes yeah yeah yeah this is a um
yeah we really had no idea how to
analyze billions per not just that like
any sustained argument against quantum
attacks um
this is really the only textbook we know
so in terms of analyzing so i have a
question
so for example when we want to get like
more concrete bounds classically we
analyze this in the random oracle model
which i know is not the problem you want
to solve but is quantum is it also easy
to handle or it doesn't become freaky so
it's not easy but it's been done as a
work of kieza mataharan spooner um that
shows that the macaulay's protocol so
random oracle version of kilian
sound compression
uh is secure against the quantum
mechanical model so it's not easy it has
to use this compressor oracle idea it's
not clear what online extraction means
otherwise
yeah well the compressor article lets
you
do it but yeah it's uh it takes part
so i guess when i say that we didn't
have synthetic arguments i
from a crypto yeah
you know instead of having a classical
adversary and a classical reduction now
you have actually quantum reduction i
mean you're handling a part of attacker
that's
so you could hopefully you could hope
for qualitatively better properties when
you have a function reduction yeah
is that normally any of these words
[Music]
that sound massive
yeah so crazy enough um
uh
so one thing you could ask like how long
does the reduction run for
um and in one of our examples do you
remember which one
uh goldberg cajon
um i think we have the simulator the
quantum simulator if our platinum
adversary runs faster than the classical
simulator the adversary yes
um this simulator will be or this
extraction will be much slower than the
possible one because this repair stuff
doesn't take constant time
yeah it's committing to the verifiers
challenges
okay so
um the goal today is to figure out how
to implement this repair set right
because if you implement a good enough
repair step then you can just keep going
and basically do the classical reduction
so just every time you create the
adversary you just have to stick this in
there sort of repair the adversary state
and get a new good adversary stage
so i want to just clarify one last thing
before we dive into it which is that
what i'm repairing is the success
probability of the adversary i am not
actually finding some way to recover the
original state s
and that
that could be information theoretically
lost this measurement really could just
lose information about it i might never
be able to get it again but what we're
going to show is that there is a way to
get back something that is as good as
the original adversary for the purposes
of this rewinding reduction because at
the end of the day all we want to do is
write down a lot of accepting
transcripts that's all we need as long
as we do this efficiently we can appeal
to that same argument we've made uh in
the classical setting
and uh if you get an intuitive level
this is like how it differs from like
underwiring technique which is sort of
morally like a trace distance
like not exactly but it thinks about
like your distance from the original
adversary it says well once i've
extracted this much information i still
have this much success probability left
and here we're saying like just forget
about the original adversary just focus
on this one metric of how likely you are
to answer on a on a random challenge and
if you like zero in on this uh it turns
out to be possible to do rewind
okay so
um before i go on let me just quickly
recalculate um key idf in the first talk
which is that
uh this lazy measurement idea for
running quantum improvers
so
we have this like naive way of running a
quantum prover where we just always
measure what it says and as alex
explained um there is this lazy way that
you can implement as long as its message
is like the opening to some collapse
finding commitment right precisely like
this commitment guarantees that if you
run the prover by first measuring
whether the response is valid and then
only measuring conditioned on knowing
that the response is valid then um
the collapsing guarantee says you can
basically ignore the second
the second measurement it's going to be
undetectable to the proofer so sort of
if your reduction fails now when you did
this and it succeeded before then that
means that there is a
violation of this collapsing property so
we can basically cancel out the step two
um but for protocols where the last
message or the method we're recording
has this collapse binding property so
the question is does killian's protocol
actually have this property and the
answer is yes as long as you pick the
hash function correctly so the hash
function
uh for this uh this tree of commitments
has to be chosen to is carlogically
satisfy this collapsing property um but
these hash functions aren't too hard to
construct you can construct them from
learning with errors any statistically
binding hash function um and so
uh
i think this notion of collapsing hash
functions is basically the quantum
analog of collision resistance so it's
really like the direct it is like what
you would expect
great so for the rest of this talk i'm
going to just think about
he's one bit outcome measurement so this
uh this pi r measurement
corresponds to when i ask the prover a
question r like that is the binary
outcome measurement that i'm doing on
the prover state uh that records whether
or not it answers correctly
so i'm going to use this measurement a
lot to be great if it's any confusion
about it
now
but this this measurement implicitly has
like the description of the approver
baked into it has to run the prover on
that challenge r like record a dancer
and see if it's valid an uncomputed
approver
so that's what this pi r will be
okay
so
uh
what is the state repair task
i am given
like an adversary state s prime which is
the result of
uh doing this binary outcome measurement
of s for a random choice of r right that
was my classical rewinding step ask it a
random question and record whether or
not it answered correctly
um so s prime is either let's say pi r
times s or it's i minus pi r and thus
um just to avoid having two things in
every slide um
i'm going to write it as pi r s but all
throughout it could be the other outcome
so
um we're going to use the marionette
waters alternating director's idea to
solve the state repair problem
um but just this is not very helpful
like where these two projectors gonna
come from um i've only written down one
projector on this slide uh so
i'm just gonna recall we did last time
and use that to get some intuition for
how basically how you design an
alternating projector's algorithm to
solve your problem okay so
um in the last talk we had this task
right we were given this verifier state
psi and this particular projector pi g
that corresponds to well if you apply pi
g to psi that corresponds to like the
state conditioned on
uh the simulator guessing correctly so
you don't have to worry about the
simulators right now just you were given
a state psi you were given a particular
projector and you wanted to
output this particular
and
conditional
way we did it was we alternated two
measurements pi zero pi g
and these projectors were chosen uh
like the following reason one of the
projectors was basically defined to
contain the initial state or its image
contains the initial state because the
initial state is psi and then some end
still of zero registers and this is just
a projector that checks that all those
end stills are zero so if i apply this
projector to my this measurement to my
initial state it would always accept
okay
and the other projector corresponds to
where we wanted to go right we wanted to
get a valid simulation at the end and so
we chose that other projector so that
that uh the image of that projector
basically contains where we want to go
and then we alternate these two things
back and forth until that high g
effector measurement accepted
so
with that in mind um
how do we apply that intuition to the
setting
uh well first we have to have like some
projector corresponding to where we are
but we actually have that right that is
pi r
we know like s prime is equal to pi r
times s formalized
um
so we know exactly how to project onto
like a state a space containing our
current
state so what is the other projector
well
we know our goal right we want to
efficiently produce some key good
adversary stage
so just to show the high level idea i'm
going to make this massive
oversimplification where i'm just going
to assume is a projective measurement
that corresponds to where we want to go
so there's i'll assume that magically
you can efficiently implement a
projector that measures whether or not
your adversary is like p successful at
least be successful so at the moment
it's not even clear that this is like a
well-defined objective measurement like
why is this even a subspace um
and why can you implement this but just
uh let's ignore that for a second let's
pretend we have this how would it work
um the proposal if you've had this
measurement is just to alternate these
two projectors back and forth the one
corresponding to where we currently are
and the one corresponding to good
adversaries like at least p successful
ability on a random challenge
you know i run the verifier i do buy g
and then i run the request back
right and now i don't know what's said
i'm in but i'm going to i know where i
want to be which is the initial state
followed by zero and
y zero that's the job
yeah but you don't have to but you don't
want to listen to it you could it could
reject and maybe you get something
that's not zeros uh and what's
fascinating about it is that that works
too right your
classical intuition is like well i
always wanted to be zero when i try but
maybe when i do the pi zero measurement
it gives me the reducting outcome right
so uh
but and the way to understand it is
through this uh jordan walla picture
um
is where you currently are
and
the target right in the other case was
pi g the target here is taipe
you want to go to but the goals are a
little different right and the last case
we wanted to go to one particular state
and here we just want to go to anywhere
in the subspace right anything that is a
p successful adversary is good enough so
it's not an exact analogy but
uh
can five even exist i mean it seems like
it's so the way i define it right now is
a little sloppy and if you took the
slide like at face value no it doesn't
exist um because uh
uh
yeah the stupid states are actually
closing basis yeah uh but we will handle
this later we'll show how to define
success probability a little more
carefully so that this doesn't exist
but uh if we sort of forget about the
subtleties and defining this and just
assume this magic object exists and we
can implement it then the repair
procedure would be kind of easy you
would just alternate these things back
and forth
and
eventually uh hope that this pi key
measurement accepts because of the
projective measurement you know where
you are when it accepts you're just
very key good adversary by definition of
5p
so this is going to be our high level
template this is what we want to do
um so we have some huge missing pieces
here
uh
first part is why does this terminate
right so even before getting this issue
of where did pipey come from like why do
we even know that with this ideal
projector pip
like why do we know that we're
eventually going to recover a good
adversary and we really want this to
happen with high probability and fairly
quickly because we're going to do this
every single time we're between like two
queries of the adversary like we'll do
this whole procedure so if this is only
succeeding with probably like three
quarters it's not going to be good
enough
be good again
so
i'm informally saying it means your
success probability on a random
challenge is p
um
but it should not yet be clear
like why that is like a subspace
and at that level like granularity is
actually not so
i'll
steps in a row or just like somewhere by
r except then somewhere that's a great
question um actually the first version
of paper did do that um but no just just
one one except isn't it somewhere you
get a pi r except and then
you finish what you get
yeah like we know
yeah we start with pi r except for i
minus power except um and then you just
ignore all the outcomes until you get a
pipey accepted yeah
um
okay so
yeah why do we terminate um we analyzed
a fairly similar thing in the last talk
we had also a sequence of alternating
projectors and we had to see why they
terminated just to argue that the zero
knowledge simulation worked
but in the last talk we could sort of
appeal to really special properties of
those two projectors
and here i haven't told you anything
about these projectors i've just told
you the definition so we don't really
know anything else about them so why do
we know that this process is going to
terminate right
um
and the insight is to like rewrite this
problem a little differently instead of
thinking about trying to
terminate or trying to get pi p to
accept starting from s prime which is my
like the state i'm trying to repair i'm
going to sort of think back to before
this disturbance even happened
i had a
state s um that was initially like a
p-good advertary so it was initially
like in the image of pip and now i'm
going to ask how long does it take
starting in one in the image of one of
the projectors
and alternating with some other
projector to get back to where you
started
so that's a rephrased question right i'm
asking like returning to the same
projector versus
returning to the same subspace versus
like going to a different one
it turns out once you rephrase the
question this way uh you actually don't
need any properties of pi r and pipe d
to say that you get back so this is a oh
no
um
this is a
so-called return to substance lemma that
says that for any two projectors if you
start the image of one and you alternate
them back and forth you're going to get
back to it and hold one step to
execution
so there's no there's no any condition
on pi r like at
how does this differ from the first part
of the talk where you did need some
condition on the photograph
uh sorry the
like last talk yeah
so yeah good in the last stop i was i
said i was in one projector and i want
to go to the image of the other one
and so i would alternate them back and
forth and how long it took depended on
like this angle theta
and my claim is that if you start in one
projector and you want to get back to it
it actually doesn't depend on theta i'm
about to explain but yeah
i think the goals are different as well
because in the previous case you wanted
a specific state and here you're relaxed
right yeah although when we were
analyzing the run time we were just
thinking about getting to the subspace
because that's just when they all were
events okay so uh that was sort of a
separate part of the analysis
also when you get there you have the
right state but we analyzed like how
long it took to get to the top space
by looking at the angles theta
so
um
this cool thing happens and
at least in two dimensions so
uh remember that when you start um
when we alternate these two projectors
back and forth in two dimensions there's
a really simple picture that explains
the probabilities that you get the
various outcomes right if i'm at this
initial say s i have this p probability
cosine squared of theta of getting the
pi r outcome and the one minus p
probability of the other outcome right
and the sort of symmetric picture
happens at every single stage of these
alternating measurements
and
basically a simple calculation shows
that the time to return to s the
starting from s to get back is just
independent of theta and the rough
intuition for this is
i guess if you imagine theta being much
smaller than i drew it on this slide um
if you started from pi r so at this s
prime state you would get to
pi p fairly quickly
um but if you started from
this uh s prime perp state it would take
you a really long time to get there
so both of those
starting states would like one would
take a long time to take a short amount
of time but if you condition on the
probabilities you get there in the first
place they cancel out and the dependence
of theta goes away
so
just by rephrasing the question this way
you can ignore this data
and
by jordan's lama which says that i can
decompose the state space for any two
projectors into a bunch of slices that
looks like this well even if they all
have different angles this analysis
works every subspace and you can show
that normally the same statement is true
for for higher dimensions
so you're saying starting from s
uh there's much higher likelihood that
i'll land at that s prime and then it's
my first
they
yeah
they exactly cancel out yes
um so we weren't the first to observe
this like cancellation by the way i
found out recently that there was a
paper that also i called this like state
restoration um but actually they were
considering like a pretty restrictive
setting where pi p is the projector onto
s
um but
uh this is actually turned out to be
true just generally
did you
see your
new transformation
yeah um
good so uh
that's going to be the subject of the
next talk actually or part of it um but
there's a few things that we want like
we want to get back with like
overwhelming probability like one minus
like inverse x squared one minus
negligible probability
um and with a singular value algorithms
like you typically have to specify some
like epsilon cut off uh like some
failure probability right some inverse
polynomial and so for like
um for a lot of these applications like
you have to
at least think a little bit about how
you would adapt a singular value
singular vector transform algorithm to
the setting
that's not something we're going to do
in this talk but it actually will be in
the next one
let me get back exactly to us or just to
some state and fight good so
very good um
in the 2d subspace you get back to
exactly the same right um but
uh more generally all we know is we get
back somewhere we don't know that we got
back to the state we started at in
particular because the components on the
different subspaces like may get
reweighted during the procedure it may
not be the original state user yet
really good question
um do i remember correctly that when you
stated jordan's lemma in the first talk
you needed the projections to be rank
one
um no yeah so so the projector's gonna
be anything
uh but in the two-dimensional slices
they are rank one
so they act in each two slices that they
are rank one projector onto a single
state
so
that's why this thing works if we had
this
imaginary measurement so let's handle
the element in the room like where does
this come from
um
okay so
where like how do we define this uh
projector pipe well
like what did we want from it right pip
is supposed to be this this measurement
that checks whether or not the prover
success probability on a random
challenge is at least some cut off p
so
the more general question here is how do
you measure the proven successful
ability
the bad news is that you can't do this
efficiently
um
the good news is that there actually is
a way to sort of approximately measure
classical probability
and we're going to see that next
um how uh
maybe a whole new technique
alternating projectors again it's just
going to be the same algorithm
um
so i'm going to do a quick uh detour
through uh some fireworks of mariette
watrus so we were using their alternate
record technique in the last talk to
um basically output a particular state
but that isn't what they wrote down
their technique to do
what they were interested in was was a q
a application learning the probability
that the q a verifier accepts a
particular witness
and we can adapt that to our setting to
estimate the success probability of the
prover like in both cases if there's
like a probability estimation going on
here
more generally this is a you can think
of this as like some kind of phase
estimation
okay so
um
the way we're going to estimate success
probability well we have to think a
little bit here just because um you know
we're talking about proverbs that are
being run on on like random challenges
right so just instead of thinking about
that i'm gonna make everything a little
more quantum and imagine running the
approver on a like a superposition of
all challenges right and so that's just
a slight rephrasing of the problem so
i'm going to write down a plus r to be a
new quantum register that's going to
contain initially a uniform
superposition of all challenges
and i'm going to define this projector
pi except that corresponds to sort of
controlling on this register so if you
read that register and you
controlled on that register you check
whether the approver answers correctly
on that challenge
so these definitions are just set so
that if i start with this grouper say
this other register to this uniform
super position then the probability that
this measurement accepts is just
precisely the success probability of the
approver
so the way we're going to learn
successful ability is by alternating
this measurement back and forth with
uh the measurement that corresponds to
the starting state so in particular the
measurement that projects uh onto
um
the the challenge register being in
uniform superposition so it's pi except
and pi uniform and we're just going to
uh
do a whole bunch of measurements
and the way that we're going to estimate
success probability is we're going to
take this list of measurement outcomes
so b1 b2 b3 up to some time bound bt
and we're gonna count the number of
times that
we get two consecutive like identical
outcomes the number of times bi equals
bi plus one
and we're going to divide that by like t
minus one
so like we're looking at the fraction of
times that you bought identical outcomes
okay so
why does this work um
what's going oh i see
it's a projection that's for sure except
from the original setup but plus our in
tensor product with the adversary stage
morally it's not too different from
setting the other register to be zero
and protecting up to zero
that's nice yeah the intuition yeah why
does this give you the success
probability that's not so clear yet
so why does this work um
again our favorite lemma let's just
pretend we're in the 2d case so let's
pretend that for whatever reason our
initial state just begins in one of
these two-dimensional jordan subspaces
where these projectors pi except in pi
uniform and so it has some success
probability at this point like why does
this algorithm extract that success
probability
right well um
okay we have this value pj right which
is the cosine squared of theta
i'm going to call it eigenvalue from now
on just for uh it's a
technically correct term it turns out to
be the eigenvalue of some operator but
don't worry about it
pj in this case we care about it because
it is the success probability of this
adversary state s
um
and alternating measurements will give
us pj
so you can just kind of see as this
thing bounces around that every time i
do another measurement right i'm here i
do a uniform measurement like my
probability of of uh
of getting the
like the same outcome again is always
going to be tj and my probability of
getting a different outcome from the one
i had last time is 1 minus pj so this is
basically like a way for me to like flip
this pj coin many times
right
and so when i'm done i just i look i did
uh nine trials so i
i i see that eight like six times out of
these out of these eight comparisons i
got the same results and so that tells
me that like a
three-fourth is a good estimate for my
for this pj value
so in general we're not going to start
in one two-dimensional subspace so this
is where things are going to get a
little more interesting um but you have
a general approver which is like some
component in like one slice and one in
the mother slice and some component in
some other 2d slice
and so let's say that somehow you you
know you have these three different
jordan subspaces
um
and my approver let's say has like some
alpha one amplitude on like the u1 on
the one subspace alpha two amplitude of
the two sub space
each of these subspaces corresponds to a
different success probability of the
prover right like the successful ability
is precisely like the eigenvalue of the
subspace
and the overall success probability of
the prover is really just the average of
these right the alpha squared weighted
average of these various accessible
abilities
um
[Music]
so the key fact is that when you do
alternating measurements on this
superposition over different 2d slices
the way that the outcome is luck well
maybe it's not like operatory clear
right if i am on like some subspace with
like one fourth and one that has like
three fourths am i going to get a
sequence that tells me like one half
or
how are these outcomes distributed
and it turns out the way it works is
it's as if like at the beginning of time
you randomly pick one of your subspaces
and then you like flip the coin
corresponding to that subspace
so it's actually very unlikely that you
would get like a one-half estimate if
you started in like a position of like
one-fourth and three fourths
it's actually that you'll see like an
estimate close to one fourth with
probably one half and close to three
fourths
so
um
and using those key facts you can kind
of understand like what happens to the
states because
uh
fundamentally like when you do a quantum
measurement the post-measurement state
is going to be like the state that is
like basically most consistent with the
outcomes you observed
right
and say i i start with this state and i
do this estimation procedure and i see
that i estimate something really close
to three-fourths
then if my state started as like a
uniform superposition over these three
subspaces then after this estimation i'm
actually going to be very concentrated
on this three-fourth subspace right
because the components on these would be
like really really inconsistent with
those outcomes i saw
so in the limit what this is doing is
it's basically implementing a
measurement onto these 2d subspaces
like you have a 2d subspace one
corresponding to each success
probability
and as i do more and more measurements
i'm essentially like concentrating
around like certain values of success
probability
so this formally is what i mean when i
say like measure successful probability
it's actually like measuring this
particular eigenvalue
and so when we want to sort of return to
a good successful ability subspace i
don't mean just like any any adversary
with like high speeds probability is
good enough i want to return to
adversaries that are sort of supported
on like the direct sum of the subspaces
where the eigenvalues are high enough
so
um
maybe that would be a good time for
questions before i continue
with very similar values similar
eigenvalues so it'll be concentrated
around those
that have an eigenvalue very close to
your estimate
but like if they're all spread out then
it sort of really is like just plopping
you to one subspace
okay can you think about this uh
repeating this process many times just
sort of a big measurement of the overlap
between these
two projectors
yeah no exactly exactly
yeah yeah exactly like
um right the
like the overlap or the angle between
these two subspaces like these one is
like the subspace for like uniformly
random challenges and one is substance
for winning or like answering correctly
on the challenge and sort of the overlap
between them corresponds to success
probability but there is a sort of
like all possible success probabilities
and your state
your adversary state has like a
component
on the different ones and you're
basically measuring where
where it is
so um
i'm going to black box this uh marion
watches estimator now that we know how
it works and to analyze our procedure
there's really like two key properties
that you need from it
um
that's suffice to to show that repair is
going to work so first is that it has
this nice like expectation property that
the expected estimate that you get is
exactly equal to the success probability
of the original state s like if this
adversary s had like p0 probability of
answering correctly on a random
challenge p0 is exactly the expectation
of
my output
um
the other property is that
this measurement actually like i was
saying like it behaves like you're
projectively measuring which subspace
you're in and you can make this a little
formal actually um so the defining
feature a defining feature of productive
measurements is that if you do them
twice they will give you the same
outcome
and this estimator like morally does
that too like if you run this estimator
twice on the same state you are going to
get two estimates that are really close
to each other right precisely because of
this concentration right as you run it
you get concentrated on like one value
of one eigenvalue and so when you run it
again you will also estimate that
eigenvalue again and so that's how you
actually can set the running time of
this that if you want to have like
epsilon closeness between two estimates
with like one minus delta probability
you can run and probably went over
epsilon log of one over delta time
so
in march andrew's paper he calls this
like epsilon delta almost projective and
it's a really good intuition for how to
think about these things i'm just
thinking of them as like behaving
morally like productive measurements
because that intuition is like what
leads to uh making this repair procedure
work
right because we sort of intuited that
like it had we written down like a
projected measurement everything would
have been fine and this thing just kind
of behaves like one at least in the
sense like its outputs look like sort of
like a projective measurement
okay so
back to what we're doing um recall this
is our high level sort of fantasy
picture for what the state repair would
look like right that we would alternate
pi r and pi key back and forth um
and
we don't know how to implement this or
the exact measurement pipe
um at least after the discussion we can
now define it like pi p should be
defined to be the projection onto all
the subspaces whose eigenvalues are at
least p
but we still we can't implement that um
but we can approximate it with this
mario walker's estimator right so um i'm
going to define mwp just to tactically
have a two outcome measurement to just
be it's going to run the marion watchers
estimator and it will accept if the
output is at least p
but that is a plausible way to test if
your success probabilities at least just
estimate and accept if it's high
sorry what is the
rate of convergence of this estimator
like how much additive error you get
after how long
um so yeah you can in time t you can
approximate to
if you want to approximate the additive
epsilon with failure probability delta
you run for poly of one over epsilon log
of one over delta so you can get like
delta to be really solid inverse
exponential
um but the the epsilon is going to be
inverse polynomial okay
did this work for an arbitrary like
state or is there something specific
about that state you're using here for
this like that whatever i give you some
state there's some verifier in the most
general setting and you're doing this
estimation right of the acceptance
probability um does it work for an
arbitrary setting like this or is there
something very specific so the epsilon
guarantee is about the outcomes of like
two consecutive executions of this
estimator so
um there's no guarantee of closeness
like the sort of original success
probability of the adversary like that
could be sort of really spread out but
it's saying that if i run it once and
concentrate it and i run it again the
second outcome was really close to the
first one
um
okay so we have this mwp which is this
the closest thing we have to the
measurement we actually wanted and so
what do we do
we're going to run mario watchers on
marriott watchers
that's what i've been building to this
is how we do rewinding um this is how
you repair this date is you replace that
with this this uh this actual thing we
can do um
okay so that's like
uh the
high level that's like
morally what we want to do um there's a
lot of issues with what's currently up
here so
um
so before i go on i just want to clarify
like
um
a subtle point that
uh when i'm saying i'm repairing the
adversary the thing that i'm restoring
is not just its success probability but
really like its structure in these like
jordan subspaces i really want it to
like strongly have p success probability
meaning that like its support is on the
eigenspaces with eigenvalue above p
right because there's ways to have like
a p successful adversary but it's like a
superposition of like 2p success and
zero success and that's not going to be
good enough i want i want it to have
like strong key success
okay and one way you can test like
strong p success or one way you can kind
of define it is like think about the
likelihood that your estimator would
would uh spit out something at least p
okay so that's really the invariant
we're going to try to maintain it's this
like notion of being strongly successful
throughout
for all time
um so it seems promising
but one issue is that
the way that we analyze like why this
procedure will terminate
is i assumed i was altering pyre with a
projective measurement back and forth
but what is this mwp right it's like
it's doing a whole bunch of little
measurements inside of it so like what
what should i do why does this even work
um it does written it probably doesn't
work um
so mwp's is not a productive measurement
right
running it twice can give different
outcomes we said they're close but
it's still not literally projective uh
productive
so
reasonable fix is you can
quantum fact is that you can take
anything that's not productive and you
can make it a productive measurement by
just considering a larger helper space
you just write down some mancilla
registers and use those to implement
this as a projected measurement and so i
can sort of
syntactically turn this into something
that i can analyze and indeed i will
terminate
but the problem is that the way you do
this is you write down some other
projected measurement pipey star
okay
and it has a property that it implements
this mario watchers estimator provided
that the ancillary registers are zero
right um
and but otherwise if they're non-zero it
has essentially no correspondence with
like what i actually wanted to do like i
want this thing to estimate the best
probability but it can only promise me
that when the ancillary registers are
zero at the moment i run it
so
that's going to be a problem because
the way that my procedure ends is that i
wait till this pipey star measurement
accepts
right but this pipey star measurement
accepting like doesn't necessarily tell
me anything useful that priority
because
maybe like when we ran it right it
didn't have zero ancillaries like how do
we how do we ensure that
right and maybe it's like giving me a
bogus estimate like it says
the estimate is one they don't or
doesn't because probability is high but
only because like some like fake number
was written there in the first place so
how do we actually know that the section
this works
um
you know i have like five months um
yeah okay
so
the solution is
that you have to redefine the other
projector
to try to reset the type star projector
so ipstar is trying to implement mwp and
we like it only works if the ancillas
are zero so you're gonna have the other
protector try to reset it back to zero
and you can notice that this is for free
in the sense that your initial state
does satisfy this property like when i
set up s prime and run it through this
procedure i should be setting the
ancillas to zero so i'm initially in the
image of this extended version of pi r
star
and this is essentially the the full
repair procedure
you run marion watches on mariette
waters where the inner marion watrus is
turned into a projector and you modify
the other projector to sort of
force the marionette launcher's
projector to behave correctly
and when you do this
you can you can repair successful
ability sure yeah after
using pi star p uh do you have the
density loss uh
we needed the silos are zero with some
probability to be able to project by our
stars now right
okay
[Music]
i start p what do you have in silos
oh yeah yeah so those are uh not
necessarily zeros but they could be zero
with some probability yeah like if you
were to measure whether they're zero yes
it'll happen with some probability
uh you're totally right this is a you
have to take care of this okay
but hear me phrase things in a very nice
abstract way saying that if you started
the image whatever projector then you
will return to it
and here you start almost completely in
the image of this pi star p and so you
will get that
yes implicitly like yeah there's
something weird going on with the
ancillas but like but because the angles
between pi star p and pi star sorry that
because you started inside
the like the badge
the bad case you're worried about only
happens
like they were they were falling
sometimes
sometimes
okay so i'm going to skip the analysis
here but i will just say like the high
level at the very top of the slide which
is that in a nutshell the reason you can
show this works is because like this
particular choice of pira star
allows you to look at the jordan sub
spaces for pi r star and [ __ ] star so
these are different these are like big
jordan subspaces because uh they're
totally different than the ones we were
considering earlier which are in the
definition of type star but for these
big jordan sub spaces um
uh
the fact that one of these projectors is
ensuring the ancillas are zero allows
you to interpret what the angles between
these in these subspaces mean
in terms of the mw procedure
and then you can appeal to the
guarantees of that to show that this is
going to work
so
let me
wrap up here the way that this works uh
this is just another picture
this repair stuff is alternating these
guys and that's all
what happens by the way is that the
guarantee you get ends up degrading a
little bit that every single time you
repair you can only guarantee that
you're like
like a little like p minus epsilon it
goes to t minus two epsilon you lose an
epsilon every single time
um
so
uh but you can set the apps on in
advance so that if you know you need
like a certain number of rewinds you you
set it to be small enough so that you
still have enough success probability
okay
so smaller epsilon will be uh
repair it for longer but yes
yeah but it's it's all polynomial
so
you said that it doesn't have to be to
accept in a row but given the thing that
you said about the insula is is it now
required that you have to accept it so
the crazy thing is that it's not
required um so one way you can analyze
this procedure is you say i only want to
finish when i have two exceptions in a
row it'll make it run like quadratically
longer and you can show that works with
like a simpler argument
but if you want to make it
it turns out this procedure has like
this memorylessness property then uh it
doesn't actually care that a
firestarter happens before and that's
kind of crazy because their intuition is
that you really need the zeros to be
there to make sense of the outcome
but turns out by like looking at the
jordan subspaces you can see that you
don't actually need it
okay so um where does this leave us well
in this talk we saw how to rewind and
obtain a lot of protocol transcripts um
this gives you post quantum soundness of
killian's protocol but generally this
like procedure for storing successful
ability is useful not just for getting
many transcripts but even for getting
two transcripts if you want to do it
with the optimal successful abilities so
you can use this to get the right
soundness error for things like plump
um since this paper has come out there's
been several applications of this to
other settings so there's a really nice
work by the baton superheroes kingdom
light that shows that this this like um
problem with quantum improvers or
quantum adversaries is not really just
like an interactive issue there's also
an issue in the non-interactive case at
least if you want sort of the best kind
of cryptographic reduction which is like
a reduction that shouldn't assume like
multiple copies of an adversary and they
they use this technique to basically
repair adversaries and make like
classical proofs like worldwide web and
go through against uh against quantum
attacks
um there's another work by uh russell
julia malavolta and nick spooner that's
actually maybe not public yet um where
they show how to extend this to like
multi-round protocols and do
things like lattice-based versions of
like bullet proofs
um and we've been upcoming work with uh
sam got nathan joe and mark zandry
showing how to use this to get uh
quantum communications distinct
arguments so for instance like the same
arguments for np that don't even require
one-way functions but like even weaker
assumptions um and you do this by
writing down like a version of this this
like rewinding that extracts quantum
information
okay so
uh have we solved bottom rewinding is
this the end of the story uh
not quite um there's still like several
fairly unsatisfying things about this
technique
um first off you actually need advice to
make it work you need classical advice
in particular um i sort of
ignored this entirely in this talk but
to make sure this invariant holds in the
first place like the very first time how
do you get a like strongly key
successful adversary you have to run
some initial estimation procedure on the
adversary
and for that you actually it turns out
you need a lower bound on the
adversary's successful ability to do
this
uh you can kind of assume that you have
it but
to me that feels a little unsatisfying
like generally the success probability
is not some physically accessible
quantity so why do you have this in the
first place
and
you're okay with non-uniform reductions
yeah
if you're okay with that then then this
is less of an issue but there are more
um so another issue is that
the running time is really bad right
because you just have to pay every
single time you want to run your
adversary and how long does the repair
procedure take uh it takes it has this
huge multiplicative overhead so you have
to run for like one over epsilon of the
five steps to extract whereas
classically like the dependency of one
over epsilon right if you
have some success probability it takes
one over epsilon tries to get the number
of trends to get like another
transcription
so there's this huge blow-up um and that
turns out to be a big issue in certain
settings we're gonna see that in the
next talk
um and finally it doesn't preserve the
proven state at all and this was
actually by design right we we said we
have to give up on exactly preserving
the group of states because information
could be lost
but it's still undesirable for like
crypto security definitions when you
want to plug this into um when you want
to like use protocols within other
protocols for instance um this the fact
that you haven't preserved the prover
state is really annoying
so
is there any way to sort of get around
this issue
okay
so this concludes uh
talking alternating projectors thanks
you're able to extract it with just that
uh
and only measure the witnesses
this this procedure
does not extract the witness with high
performance
[Music]
yeah so this uh what's happening here
that there's this initial estimation of
the average phase of probability and
that estimate is too low it just doesn't
even try
and so there's this like probability you
just fail to start so
like when you say like extract with
probability one you have to be really
careful about like in what sense the
probability you want like condition on
what
all right so but if it is one minus like
this
but if it's not then you don't know how
to cope with it
yeah so i guess defining like what it
means to like have the extractor work is
like a big part of the next talk um but
in just this paper we like kind of
didn't really answer that question
just just wanting these factors to see
the same probability that proverbs
okay
so 2 o'clock and alex will tell us
you